CNN is a business in trouble I'm going
to show you they had a product problem
maybe your company has had a product
problem maybe that's been the source of
some things there's product and
Leadership once you're an existing
company you either lack leadership maybe
it's sales maybe it's technology maybe
whatever it is or you have a product
problem people aren't buying it anymore
someone else has a lower price or a
better product that's usually where it
starts CNN had a product problem and I'm
going to show it to you because
while Chris licked and some recent
things may have been the last straw and
that's why he left the company over the
weekend I'm going to show you that the
that the first straw
was really where it started and that was
under the leadership of a guy named Jeff
Zucker who was at CNN and the product
changed dramatically